So Fastly's a CDN.
Like I said, we're kind
of a next generation,
although that's kind of
a cheesy marketing term.
You probably actually use
us without knowing about us.
This is some our customers.
We've got Twitter on there, BBC.
The British government
runs through us,
which is kind of cool,
although a bit scary.
This is also some
of our customers.
I realize, actually, in
retrospect, some of those
are duplicated.
I promise you that's
me screwing up,
not me trying to pad the stuff.
This is going to be
less video oriented
than some of the other
stuff, although we will shove
some video stuff in at the end.
This is more about just
like why we're different,
why we did a CDN, and sort
of just go on from there.
So yeah, if I rush through
stuff, I apologize.
Grab me afterwards .
I'm going to be at
the cocktail party,
trying to surf my sort
of, whatever, sine waves--
the things-- circadian
rhythms, that's the one.
Sine waves?
Yeah.
So people, when we started
off, people asked us like, why?
Why did you build a CDN?
You've got Akamai--
they're the 800 pound
gorilla in the room-- you've got
EdgeCast, you've got Limelight.
Amazon is in the business.
Like, why would you do this?
And basically it's
because we were
really unhappy with the way that
the CDN market was at the time.
You didn't get a lot of
control, configuration
was really crappy.
When you made a
configuration change
it could take, at best, minutes,
sometimes hours to do stuff.
You don't have a lot of
control over your data.
When you wanted to purge
stuff, again minutes or hours
to change stuff
which, when you're
dealing with a
modern content site,
and you didn't get
a lot of visibility
and you were locked into
these year-long contracts,
it was crappy.
It was just a really
crappy way of doing stuff
and it didn't really fit in with
the way we do development now.
Like yeah, sure, when we used
to have a release once a week,
or once a month, that was fine.
But now people do 10,
12, 20 releases a day.
That didn't really
work that well.
And also the support
was kind of crap.
Like every time you phoned up
the support thing, you dreaded.
You had to go through
your sales rep
and then they would try
to upsell on something.
And you'd be like, no, I
just want to figure out
how to do this thing.
I don't want to
have to pay for two
hours of professional services.
So we were like, enough.
We will build our own.
And it worked out.
And this [INAUDIBLE].
This is our pop map.
It's actually
already out of date.
Stockholm is already
up, Asaka is coming up,
I think sometime soon.
We're looking at Brazil.
We're also looking at a bunch
of other places, Taipei, Seoul,
South Africa.
It's actually really easy
for us to bring up pops.
So like, based on
market stuff, it
could be ready you know--
if you're looking on
here and going
well, you don't have
a place where I need it, come
talk to us anyway because it's
really easy for us
to bring up a pop,
unless there's really odd,
local-- unless there's
really odd local laws.
Like Brazil is actually
a real pain in the arse,
for various reasons.
Come talk to me afterwards
when I'm drinking.
Because it makes
me want to drink.
So why would you use--
why would you use Fastly?
This is the kind of sales event.
When it started off like--
so what we started off doing,
I suggested one of our slogans
should be "faster, cheaper,
better, pick three."
Turns out that's why I
should never be in marketing.
But basically, we
can make your--
we basically can make
your site faster,
we can lower your
costs, and we could
make your site more reliable.
And we're basically
trying to lower
your total cost of ownership.
Total cost of ownership is
made up of multiple assets,
and it's everything
from reliability
to geographic
distribution, it's control,
to visibility, to how fast
you can go and do stuff.
And so really, we wanted
to be part of that view.
We can reduce your
CAPEX and OPEX.
By going through
us, you don't have
to have as many origin servers.
And so therefore,
your CAPEX is lower.
And also, our
bandwidth costs are
going to be lower than
yours because we've
got economies and scale.
Unless you're Google, in which
case-- but even Google use us,
so that should
tell you something.
And so, we can reduce
your OPEX as well.
If you're using us, we've
got a really sweetheart deal
with Google, when it comes
to egress from Google Cloud
Storage, so that will
lower you Google costs.
Thank you very much, Google.
And go and talk
to our sales guys,
they will tell you kind of
how much you'll be saving.
You don't need as
much redundancy.
You can have one data center
and we will take care of that.
Or you don't need quite
as many data centers.
We will reduce your bounce rate.
The faster your site is and
the more reliable it is,
the more likely people
are to come back.
And because of that,
because of the faster rate
we'll increase your page rank.
And so that means more
people will come to you.
We'll increase your
revenue because there
is a really, really well
known link between how
fast your site loads and how
much money people spend on it.
You can intuitively
kind of grasp that.
If you go to a site and you are
trying to buy something from it
and it takes two seconds
for each page to load,
you'll look at four
items and then go,
you know what, I'm giving up.
Whereas if it loads
really quickly,
you're much more likely
to spend time around.
And because of that,
people are going
to spend more time on the site.
So there's that neat symmetry.
We'll reduce some stuff for you,
we'll increase other things.
The reason why we
kind of can do this
is that, back in the early
'90s-- sorry, early '90s.
Back in the late
'90s early 2000s,
really content was basically
into either static content--
like images, CSS,
JavaScript, all that kind
of stuff-- or it was fully
dynamic stuff, running
[INAUDIBLE] scripts through
modperl, or like ASP,
or PHP 3.0, for anybody
who's old school.
And it was mostly-- those two
concepts, completely separate.
It was either stuff was either
static or it was dynamic,
and never the twain shall meet.
Nowadays, we have this term--
we started using this term,
"event-driven content" mostly
because we needed some sort
of marketing term rather than
trying to explain it every
time.
But that's basically
stuff like content
doesn't actually
change that often.
So you're looking at stuff like
the front page of a newspaper
or something like that.
Everybody's looking at
the same front page,
it's dynamically generated,
but realistically, it's
sticking around for five
minutes or something like that.
It doesn't actually
change that much.
Something triggers it
that causes a change.
Somebody publishes a new
story, stock market changes,
a new event happens or
something like that.
You get a new mail.
All that stuff is event-driven,
it's not truly dynamic.
So that's where we can come in.
And that's actually a
huge amount of your stuff.
And we can cache
that for you, then
you can save yourself
a huge amount
of-- you can make
your page a lot faster
and you can save yourself
a huge amount of bandwidth.
So statically kind of
stuff, we can drastically
increase your cache hit ratio.
Sorry, I just realized
the conversion of this
from PowerPoint hasn't
actually gone as well as it,
so stuff is going off.
So with traditional
static stuff,
we can cache it
really well for you.
We use math-- we
call these commodity
servers because they're
built of commodity parts,
but they tend to
have 768 gigs of RAM,
they tend to have terabytes
and terabytes of SSDs.
We wrote our own file system.
It seemed like a really
good idea at the time.
This reason why we're doing that
is we don't need a regular file
system, all we need to do is
put cached objects down on disk.
And if we can look
after the file--
we can look after the
SSD, we can get rid
of all that overhead.
The smaller the cached object
is on disk, the more stuff
we can stick on the SSD.
And if we look after the
SSD, instead of burning out
after three months,
we've got SSDs
which are now three years old.
And the advantage of using SSDs
is that they go really, really
fast.
And I'm going to go into
that a little bit later on.
We're really good for
this kind of stuff.
You may notice at the bottom,
that's us, we're really fast.
Catchpoint is like a
monitoring and testing service.
Also, look how smooth we are.
So we're calm, ordered people.
So then there's dynamic content.
This is purely dynamic content.
I think Akamai calls this DSA,
dynamic site acceleration.
They sell it as an add on.
I'm not trying to bag on
Akamai, they're big for a reason
and they do some really,
really important work,
just using the kind of
terms that they use.
Dynamic content,
you can't cache it.
Let's say it's like the current
time or something like that,
you can't cache it.
Or somebody's very,
very personal data,
you can't cache it.
That's fine, we
will accelerate it.
And the reason why
we can do that is you
can have an initial connection
to one of pop servers which
is closer to your users.
The TCP, the three way handshake
that TCP does at the start
will be a lot quicker
because the latency
between your user and our pop
is going to be a lot better.
And then, between
our pops, we keep
keepalives between our pops.
And we know the best
route between them,
and at the other
end, we will then
go back to your origin servers.
And again, the
three way handshake
will be a lot faster between
what we call our shield node
and between your origin,
that will be a lot faster.
And also we can try and keep
a keepalive back to you.
So even when we can't
cache something,
we will make it faster.
And for us though, instead of
being an additional product
that you buy and it's like an
extra line item on your bill,
for us it's the
worst case scenario
when we can't do anything else.
We will try as hard as
possible to cache stuff,
but if we can't cache it, we
will still make it faster.
And that's just considered,
well, in the worst case
scenario, we'll do that.
So I won't read the
quotes from the side.
So once again, we rock.
I'm not entirely sure what
happened on February the 21st,
apparently everybody
had a bad day.
Yeah.
So we just like showing
these graphs, they're nice.
So then we go on to this
third type of caching.
And this is what we call
event-driven content.
And that's stuff like API,
mobile stuff, news articles,
user generated
content like wikis.
We actually kind of started
off as part of Wikia.
So if you've ever
used like-- you
may or may not know about Wikia.
But basically, if you
go to a game site,
or if you go to Wikipedia,
if you're into "Star Wars,"
or if you go to the Muppet
Wiki if you're into Muppets--
and if you're not, I don't
really want to know you--
then you use Wikia.
And in turn, you're
actually using us.
And you think about a wiki.
Like media Wikia is
not the best piece
of written piece of software.
It's great, but it's not the
best written piece of software.
It's really slow.
And you think about it,
it's a very, very long tail.
And if you had to do kind
of traditional stuff,
baking all the pages and
loading them into a CVN,
then that would be
terrible because you
would be uploading
a lot of stuff
and you don't know if
it's going to get used.
Nobody's really
necessarily going
to look at the list of the
names of every single Luke
Skywalker's lightsabers,
if you gave them names.
I'm picking an example
completely at random here.
But then, when a wiki
changes-- WoW wiki gets
updated a lot when a new
WoW expansion comes out--
then stuff changes
really quickly.
You can't be waiting
eight minutes,
let alone eight hours
for a page you updated.
eCommerce sites are
obviously a really big thing.
They're kind of just like
content publishing sites,
but when prices change
and inventories change,
you really need to
update the page quickly.
Sports scores are another thing.
They don't change for ages, like
the Dodgers game last night,
it doesn't change for ages,
but then when it does change,
you really need
to update quickly.
So yeah, people like that.
We've got "The Guardian."
I always bring up "The Guardian"
because it my first sales,
even though I'm an engineer.
It was kind of weird.
It was a bittersweet
moment for me.
I kind of felt a
bit of my soul die.
And Shazam and all that kind
of content, stuff like that.
And Conde Nast.
And so Wired run
through us, which
gave me a massive geek thrill.
So the features that really kind
of do that, we have real-time
purging.
When you purge content from
us, you can say, be gone.
And we will be like, OK.
And in 150 milliseconds,
worldwide, it's gone.
And that's huge.
We actually have three
different ways of purging stuff.
You can either purge
by URL, you can
purge by something we call
surrogate key purging, which
is when you can tag
content with multiple keys.
So each bit of content can have
multiple keys attached to it.
And each key can have multiple
objects attached to it.
So it's a really handy way
of grouping stuff together.
So you know, if you've got
up at the obvious thing
is like if you've got an article
on site, you've got the page.
You've got one or more pages
with one more images or assets
in it, you tag them all
with the same article ID.
If that article needs to
get updated, you purge it,
all those things are gone.
You can also tag
with the author.
So if you're "The New York
Time" and you find out
one of your authors has
being plagiarizing everything
and you need to purge
everything by that author,
do one call and it's all gone.
We do real-time logs.
This would be
useless-- you caching
stuff would be absolutely
useless if you didn't
know what was going on with it.
And so we can stream logs
back to you in real-time.
And again, we'll go in
to a bit of that later.
Kind of skipping over stuff
just in case I go over time.
We have this origin
shield, which is this idea
that you can do
multi-tiered caching.
So basically, stuff comes in
to one of our edge servers,
and then we will reroute
any cache misses back
to an origin pop,
which is as close as
possible to your origin.
And then that will
shield all your requests.
It will make sure that you
only have one request of it
going back to your origin.
It protects you from
stampeding herds.
And also, like I said, it gives
this much, much faster kind
of response, because
we know the best
route between all our pops.
And we can keep keepalives
between our shield pops
and with the origin.
And then we also do
request collapsing.
If two people are
coming and asking
for the same bit of
content at the same time,
we will recognize that
and then collapse it down
into one request.
So again, just when
you purge something,
you don't see this
massive spike in traffic,
which would mean you
still have to keep
this kind of redundant
hardware around.
So the benefits of that
should be pretty obvious.
Your site is a lot
faster, you can handle
unpredictable traffic spikes.
If you're the "Boston
Globe" and you finally
get into the World Series
or something like that,
then you're going to see a
massive spike in traffic.
If you're the "Guardian"
newspaper and a royal baby
is born, then that's
going to happen as well.
We also give you this
real-time configurability.
You can change your config and
have it deployed everywhere
in like, two seconds, worldwide.
Everything is API driven.
We do have the UI
on top of that,
but everything is API
driven because we don't know
how you want to configure us.
If you want to build this into
your puppet chain or your Chef
or whatever, then that's cool.
If you want to rig
us into something,
that's absolutely fine.
We want to work with
you how you work,
no force you to work how we do.
And we're trying to give you
total control of your content.
You can send us
back cache edges.
You can override
everything in our UI.
You can actually
upload edge scripting
to override everything.
We don't know how
you use your content,
so we want to give you
the control to do stuff.
It's also kind of proactive
laziness on our part.
The more you can do stuff,
the less we have to do
and that's really great.
Especially back when
we were starting off,
it meant I could actually sleep
and spend more time welding
giant metal ears.
And so we're trying
to lower your CAPEX.
And basically, the
way we were able to do
this, when we started
off, people were kind of,
how are you going to
compete against Akamai?
How are you're going to
compete against EdgeCast?
How are you going to be
compete against Limelight?
They're so much bigger, they
have economies of scale,
you're going to
be too expensive.
And basically,
they were all built
on-- you may notice the
back of my thing says,
life is too short
to use and 90 CVN.
Rather than build a network
back in the early 2000s
when the internet
was very different.
It was crappy.
Late '90s, early 2000s,
things were really crappy.
Now, things are a lot better.
And we can do stuff by
building much fewer pops
at internet backbones,
rather than at local ISPs.
We can build much larger pops.
We can use SSDs.
The big problem with
using regular hard drives
is the more space you've got,
the slower the averaging sheet
time is going to be because
the sheet time is linear.
Sorry, is linear
compared to size.
Because it just takes
wider-- you know,
it's just a spinning bit of
rust with a head moving over it.
So it's going to
take longer to do.
With an SSD, lookup times
are completely constant.
So we can have much, much larger
pops, much, much larger drives,
which means it's much
more likely your stuff is
going to be in cache.
SSDs is a really high
cost per gigabyte,
but they're really
low cost per IOP.
I mean, you were talking
about 70,000 IOPs
per second compared
to like seven
for a really high end hard
drive or something like that.
So we can get a lot more
performance out of our pops.
We get a lot more
efficiency and then
we can pass those costs over.
You increased
cache-hit ratio just
means you get less traffic back
to you, which is really good.
And if you think
about it, we can
increase your cache-hit
ratio from 90% to say 95%,
it doesn't sound
that impressive.
But actually what
we've just done
is halved your
origin traffic back.
So that means you can get
rid of half your servers.
And not only that but then
all that content-- like,
serving stuff from
the cache is going
to be so much faster than having
to go back to your origin,
you running whatever
app, rails app,
whatever PHP in the background,
and then go back again.
That request has gone from
being 500 milliseconds a second
or something like
that, it's come back,
we're responding to it
within 20 milliseconds.
So your page is going
to be a lot, lot faster.
And then I've already kind
of talked about origin shield
quite a lot, so I won't.
And we try to give
you more control.
We should be integrated
into your development cycle.
When people think
about Cloud, when
they think about
Google Cloud platform,
when they think about AWS and
stuff like that, the reason why
it took off is
because people can--
it fits in with the
way you do stuff.
It doesn't feel like there's
a vendor you're throwing stuff
into.
It feels like it's much more
part of your development stack.
OK, that worked.
We wanted to be
complete self-service.
You shouldn't have
to phone up and get
hold of professional services
just to change something.
When you push a
configuration change,
it should happen in seconds.
All configurations
should be versioned,
so you should be
able to roll back.
And between those two
things, it gives you
a lot more power to do
stuff and a lot more freedom
to experiment.
If you made a change
and it took five hours
to sort of propagate, and
then when you finished,
it was screwed up,
you'd be like, oh god,
that's really bad.
Now I've got to make a
change and wait another five
hours for it to fix itself.
And you're going to be much
less likely to change things.
You're going to be
much more worried.
It's going to be a
lot more fragile.
You can make a change,
notice immediately
from the real-time feedback
from the analytics and the logs
that something's gone wrong
and immediately either rollback
or make push the fix, you're
much more likely to go,
OK, I'm going to
try other stuff.
I'm going to try and
play around and see
what more stuff I can
move t the edge servers.
And then that's going to
be more beneficial to you.
So we were trying--
we really wanted
to create a system in
which you could do that.
As I said, all functionality is
available via the API or a UI.
And we've got this really
powerful edge scripting
based on something called
varnish configuration
language or VCL.
VCL is basically a domain
specific language that
lets you do anything with HTP.
It's really, really powerful.
So you can do a lot more stuff.
You can move a lot more
content to the edge.
And we've got stuff on there.
We've got edge
authorization and Paywall
We can do stuff based on
Geo IP and Geo restrictions.
So if you've got
content that shouldn't
be shown to some people but
should be shown to other,
you can do that
through authorization.
You can do mobile
device detection.
You can do shopper
prioritization.
It's when, you know,
if your origin server,
your credit card payment
server is pretty loaded
during the holiday period,
you can sit there and go,
OK, well we'll just show up
a warning, a page saying,
we're really sorry, your
order is very important to us,
you'll be able to pay soon.
But then you can also look
and ago, oh, this person
has the VIP flag.
Or this person's got like
$10,000 worth of stuff
in their shopping basket.
We're going to silently move
them off to the VIP server,
and just allowance them
to go through as well.
We can do all your
load balancing for you.
Our CO is very, very
much against F5s.
He really hates them, so he
basically wanted that built in.
And we can do stuff like data
collection stuff, Internet
of Things stuff.
That's less relevant to
the rendering people here,
but I thought I'd
mention it anyway.
And this is kind of
an example of VCL.
This is a way of having
a different edition
for your content.
So like, if somebody's
coming from international,
somebody's coming
from mobile and stuff,
you could redirect around.
It's kind of a
contrived example,
but it's in here for
illustrative purposes.
Like I said, content purging
happens in 150 milliseconds.
You can purge by URL.
You have complete control over
what is defined as a cache key,
so you can make some stuff
unique, some stuff not.
So that can include,
say, somebody's language
which they prefer to speak, or
whether or not the URL has URL
parameters or something in it.
And you can purge by
this surrogate key stuff
that I was talking about.
Sorry, I'm rushing
because I'm noticing
the clock's ticking down.
And like I said, we want to
give you more visibility.
So we've got real-time logging
with completely customizable
logs.
We give you real-time stats,
we give you historical stats.
And this gives you
this greater confidence
being able to change.
And the more
confidence you've got,
the more stuff you're
going to cache.
The more cache and stuff
you're caching with us,
the more you owe us money,
and that makes us happy.
That was a joke.
But it's true.
But it's also a joke.
I probably scared you away.
This is like an example, and
I don't think I've probably
got time to go through it.
We can cache content.
Even if you've got tracking
cookies inside your content,
we can cache that.
You can track people
through the site.
Normally, a tracking
cookie would
be unique to a user, that
means you can't really--
that means you can't
really cache that at all.
What we can do is generate
the cookie at the edge
and then track it back, and
then send it back via log.
So even if you've got a
site with a tracking cookie,
you can still cache it.
You can precisely
follow video viewing,
if you're using HLS, or HDS, or
dash, or something like that,
each of those is video
separated into chunks,
so you can fire a log
event for each chunk.
You can also see how many bytes
we sent back versus the content
length of the chunk, and say
the session ID or the user
ID if the user is logged in.
So then, if you're a large
specialist video site--
so for example, they're not
actually a customer of ours,
but they did a
thing which showed
that people tend to watch the
first 30 seconds of videos,
skip about three
minutes in and then
skip to the end-- you could
see that through the logging.
They're not actually
a customer of ours,
but they wrote a really
interesting essay on it.
And this was kind of,
this is other stuff
that we can show you
from real-time tracking.
So this is from the Super Bowl.
We call this Beyonce effect,
or the Beyonce drop internally.
This is when you can see where
all the advert breaks are.
Interesting enough,
during the Super Bowl,
people stop being on the
internet during the adverts.
So we can actually
tell you which
adverts were most
successful during the break.
And we can also tell you
when Beyonce came on stage.
And we can also tell
you that Beyonce
was far, far more popular than
Bruno Mars and The Red Hot
Chili Peppers.
Like, way more popular.
And I suspect that's why
Katy Perry was on this year.
So I don't think I've got time
to go into how we're working
with Google Cloud
Platform, but basically,
we basically seamlessly
integrated into them.
You use us, you get lower
egress costs from Google.
And you get really,
really good-- you get
really good performance speeds.
And Google are
awesome, and they've
been really great for us.
And I've basically
been touring the world,
going and meeting all
the GCP people, which
is why I'm really
jet-lagged, caffeinated,
and why I'm speaking so fast.
So basically I'm out
of time, so if you've
got any more questions,
come grab me afterwards,
or talk to me at the
event afterwards.